call me dude Z any company that has
giant AIS is only going to be plowing
Straight Ahead making them as powerful
as possible you think China's gonna be
like okay Elon Musk signed a letter
we'll get rid of all of our military
absolutely not this is an arms
race period it's already started if you
try to bail out now there's just no
point in doing it the best case scenario
with AI
is it becomes so smart that we
don't even understand how it exists and
does what it does and it is a hopefully
benevolent God to us hopefully yeah no
this is this is humankind romping
stomping Homo sapiens rule we
take out sharks we eat them that's what
they do in China shark fin soup right
beautiful animal
it's soup now we did it
we won